Aquí hay cinco extinciones masivas
indicadas por los triángulos amarillos, y nosotros somos la siguiente.
La última, a la extrema derecha,
es la del meteoro que chocó hace 66 millones de años
y acabó con los dinosaurios.
Y el cuento es que nosotros somos el siguiente meteoro.
El asunto es este, lo investigué para un ensayo que escribí:
extinción masiva es cuando el 75 % de las especies del mundo se extingue.
Hay unos cinco millones y medio de especies,
de las que hemos identificado un millón y medio.
Otras 14 000 se identifican cada año.
Hay mucha biología sucediendo por ahí.
Desde 1500 se han extinguido unas 500 especies.
Uno ve al término 'extinción masiva' usado en maneras extrañas.
Hace como año y medio un artículo de Carl Zimmer
en la primera página del New York Times
se titulaba 'Extinción masiva en los océanos, según estudios'.
Uno lee el artículo y menciona que desde 1500
quince especies,
quince, se han extinguido en los océanos
y, por cierto, ninguna en los últimos 50 años.
Uno sigue leyendo y dice
que lo terrorífico es que las pesquerías sobrepescan tanto a los peces silvestres
que la población de los océanos está disminuyendo en un 38 %.
Eso es lo grave.
Probablemente, ninguna de esas especies se extinguirá.
Así que
quien escribió ese titular puso un botón de pánico al inicio de la historia.
Es un recurso para atraer lectores que, básicamente, dice:
"¡Dios mío!, entren en pánico, perderemos todas las especies de los océanos".
Nada de eso está por ocurrir.
De hecho, ahí empecé a estudiar el asunto con más detenimiento.
La Lista Roja muestra 23 000 especies que se consideran amenazadas
de una manera u otra.
Es publicada por la Unión Internacional para la Conservación de la Naturaleza.
Y la revista 'Nature Magazine'
tenía un artículo sobre la pérdida de vida silvestre que decía:
"Si esas 23 000 especies se extinguieran en el próximo siglo
y ese ritmo de extinción continuara durante siglos y milenios,
entonces podríamos estar en el principio
de la sexta extinción".
Así que la exageración es desproporcionada,
pero los ambientalistas siempre exageran, ese es el problema.
CA: Probablemente sienten que tienen una responsabilidad moral
ya que les importa tanto lo que están observando.
Y si no hicieran un escándalo, tal vez nadie los escucharía.
SB: Cada vez que alguien dice la moral por aquí, la moral por allá...
'Riesgo moral', 'principio de precaución'
son términos que se usan para decir no.
(Risas)
CA: ¿Así que el problema no es tanto la extinción de peces o animales,
sino el aumento de los peces y animales?
¿Que los estamos hacinando?
SB: Sí, creo que los estamos hacinando y también se dan pérdidas.
Las mayores pérdidas son causadas por la agricultura,
así que cualquier cosa que mejore la agricultura,
que la condense más y la haga más productiva,
incluyendo los OGM, por favor;
incluyendo las granjas verticales en la ciudad y las granjas interiores;
todo lo que se ha aprendido sobre el cultivo de marihuana en sótanos
está siendo aplicado para cultivar vegetales en un contenedor;
todo eso es grandioso y bueno
porque liberar tierra es lo principal que podemos hacer por la naturaleza.
Que la gente se traslade a las ciudades es bueno,
que la agricultura destruya menos el paisaje es bueno.
CA: Hay gente que habla de revivir especies y resilvestración...
Resilvestración: ¿Cuál es la historia de estos sujetos?
SB: ¡Ajá! Lobos.
Europa.
Retomando el punto anterior,
quizá las tierras de cultivo hayan alcanzado su clímax,
también la población, quizá estamos en el número tope de niños.
De aquí en adelante habrá cada vez menos niños.
Estamos en la última duplicación de la población humana,
llegará hasta nueve, quizá nueve mil millones y medio
y de ahí no solo se mantendrá, sino que empezará a disminuir.
También la tierra de cultivo está en su clímax.
Y una manera
en que eso se manifiesta en Europa
es que ahora hay muchas tierras de cultivo abandonadas,
que inmediatamente se reforestan.
No crean corredores ecológicos en Europa, no los necesitan,
tantas de estas granjas están conectadas
que han creado corredores ecológicos reforestados
a los que los lobos están regresando, en este caso a España.
Han avanzado hasta Holanda.
Los osos están regresando, los linces están regresando.
Hay un chacal europeo, que no sabía que existía,
que está regresando desde Italia y del resto de Europa.
Y a diferencia de aquí, todos son predadores, lo que es interesante.
Los europeos les están dando la bienvenida, los habían extrañado.
CA: Y contraintuitivamente, cuando reintroducen predadores
con frecuencia aumenta, y no disminuye, la diversidad del ecosistema.
SB: Sí, generalmente los predadores, animales grandes
y animales grandes con dientes y garras afilados,
han resultado muy importantes para crear un ecosistema realmente abundante.
CA: Lo que nos lleva a este proyecto más dramático de resilvestración
en el que está involucrado.
¿Por qué alguien querría reintroducir a estos aterradores mamuts lanudos?
SB: Los elefantes asiáticos son los parientes más cercanos
del mamut lanudo
y son casi del mismo tamaño, son muy cercanos genéticamente.
Divergieron recientemente
en la historia evolutiva.
Los elefantes asiáticos están más cerca del mamut lanudo
que del elefante africano,
pero están lo suficientemente cerca de los africanos
para haberse hibridado con éxito.
Así que estamos trabajando con George Church en Harvard.
George ya ha trasladado los genes de cuatro rasgos principales
del ahora bien preservado, bien estudiado genoma del mamut lanudo,
gracias al 'análisis del ADN antiguo'.
Y en el laboratorio ha trasladado esos genes
a líneas celulares de elefantes asiáticos vivos,
y están ubicándose en el lugar correspondiente gracias a CRISPR.
No están disparando los genes como se hacía en ingeniería genética.
Ahora con CRISPR,
básicamente, están editando un alelo y reemplazándolo por otro alelo.
Así que tenemos células de la línea germinal de elefantes asiáticos
que, con respecto a las características que deseamos,
estarán cómodos en el Ártico...
las metimos en la mezcla.
Así que pasamos por el proceso de introducirlas
a través de la madre sustituta, que es una elefanta asiática.
Puedes usar un sustituto, como lo llaman los biólogos conservacionistas, del mamut,
que en la práctica es un peludo elefante asiático de trompa enroscada
que se siente sumamente cómodo en el subártico.
Ahora, mucha gente pregunta: "¿Cómo los vas a llevar allá?
A los elefantes asiáticos no les gusta la nieve".
Bueno, resulta que sí les gusta, hay unos en el zoológico de Ontario
que han hecho bolas de nieve más grandes que un humano.
Les encanta, con una trompa pueden empezar algo pequeño,
rodarlo y hacerlo más grande.
De ahí la gente dice:
"Pero son 22 meses de gestación.
Este tipo de clonación interespecies es un asunto complicado,
¿vas a perder algunas de las elefantas que serán madres sustitutas?"
George Church dice: "Bueno, construiremos un útero artificial".
Y la gente dice: "Claro, tal vez el próximo siglo".
Excepto que 'Nature' divulgó esta semana que ya hay un útero artificial
en el que un cordero ha crecido hasta las cuatro semanas.
Esa es la mitad de su periodo de gestación.
Así que esto está avanzando.
CA: Pero por qué debiéramos querer un mundo...
Imaginemos un mundo donde miles de estas creaturas
corretean por Siberia.
¿Sería un mundo mejor?
SB: Potencialmente. Es...
(Risas)
Hay tres grupos trabajando seriamente con el mamut lanudo:
Revive & Restore, que estamos en el medio;
George Church y los de Harvard se encargan de genética en el laboratorio
y de ahí está este fantástico científico mayor que se llama Zimov
y que trabaja en el norte de Siberia
con su hijo Nikita, que también cree en esto.
Sergey y Nikita Zimov han estado, durante 25 años,
creando lo que llaman 'Parque Pleistoceno'
en una parte realmente hostil de Siberia que es pura tundra.
Y los estudios muestran
que en ese paraje hay, probablemente, 1/100 de los animales que solía haber,
como la imagen anterior que tenía muchísimos animales.
Ahora no hay casi ninguno.
La tundra es mayormente musgo y también está el bosque boreal.
Así es como está la cosa, solo hay pocos animales.
Así que introdujeron muchos animales que pastan:
bueyes almizcleros, caballos de Yakutia, bisontes,
ahora están introduciendo más bisontes,
y han recreado la densidad en la que solían estar.
Los animales que pastan son los que producen las praderas.
Así que estos animales están allí pastando,
con lo que hacen un par de cosas.
Antes que todo, convierten la tundra, el musgo, en praderas.
Las praderas fijan el carbono.
La tundra, en un mundo que se calienta, está emanando mucho dióxido de carbono
y también metano.
Así que en sus pequeños 65 kilómetros cuadrados
están estabilizando el clima.
Parte de esa situación
es que el bosque boreal absorbe enormemente la luz solar,
incluso en el invierno cuando hay nieve en el suelo.
Y la estepa del mamut solía envolver todo el Polo Norte,
y hay una gran masa de tierra que rodea al Polo Norte.
Todo eso era pradera y la estepa era magnífica,
probablemente era uno de los biomas más productivos del mundo,
el bioma más grande del mundo.
En cuanto al bosque, Sergey Zimov y Nikita
salen en su viejo tanque militar, que compraron baratísimo,
y tumban árboles.
Y eso es aburrido, es cansado
y como dice Sergey: "¡Y no produce estiércol!",
que, por cierto, todos estos animales producen, incluyendo los mamuts.
Los mamuts se convierten
en lo que los biólogos conservacionistas llaman 'especie paraguas'.
Es un animal emocionante, como los pandas en China.
En la emoción de darle una buena vida a ese animal
se crea un hábitat, un ecosistema, que es bueno para muchas creaturas y plantas.
E, idealmente, llega un momento en que se maneja solo
y los biólogos conservacionistas pueden retroceder y decir:
"Con que mantengamos alejadas a las 'invasoras destructivas'
esto funcionará".
CA: Hay muchas otras especies que Ud. sueña con resilvestrar más adelante,
pero quisiera ahondar en lo que dijo
sobre cómo los mamuts pueden ayudar a enverdecer Siberia,
no estoy hablando
del bosque tropical, pero ha pensado mucho en la idea de reverdecer el planeta
y la narrativa tradicional dice que la deforestación
es una de las peores maldiciones de los tiempos modernos
y que contribuye enormemente al cambio climático.
Pero Ud. me mandó
este gráfico o mapa.
¿Qué muestra este mapa?
SB: Verdeado global.
Lo que hay que hacer con cualquier narrativa que proviene de los titulares
o de las noticias cortas
es averiguar qué más está sucediendo,
buscar lo que Marc Andreessen llama la 'violación de la narrativa'.
La narrativa, y Al Gore es un campeón para difundirla,
es que se aproxima
un rápido cambio climático que amenaza a la civilización:
tenemos que parar la producción extra de gases de efecto invernadero,
especialmente CO2, cuanto antes o tendremos serios problemas.
Todo eso es cierto, pero no es toda la historia.
Y la historia completa es más interesante que las historias fragmentarias.
Las plantas aman al CO2.
La combinación de CO2, agua y luz solar produce plantas.
Por eso, muchos invernaderos industriales añaden CO2
porque las plantas lo convierten en materia vegetal.
Y se han hecho estudios con satélites y otras cosas.
Este gráfico de, aproximadamente, los últimos 33 años
muestra que hay un 14 % más de acción a nivel de las hojas,
hay muchísima más biomasa
y de lo que los ecologistas llaman 'producción primaria'.
Hay muchísima más vida gracias al cambio climático,
gracias a nuestras benditas fábricas a base de carbón.
Así que, ¿qué está sucediendo?
Por cierto, la producción de cultivos aumenta con esto.
Esto contrarresta parcialmente
el aumento del CO2
porque hay muchas más plantas que lo convierten en materia vegetal.
Algo de eso se descompone y vuelve a subir,
pero una parte va a las raíces y al suelo y permanece allí.
Así que es necesario considerar estos factores contrarrestantes.
La historia completa es que
pensar sobre, lidiar con y modificar el clima es un proceso muy complejo.
Es como la medicina.
Hay que ir, repito, ajustando el sistema
para ver qué causa una mejoría.
Repetimos la acción para ver si sigue mejorando... fue demasiado, retrocedamos.
CA: Pero alguna gente dice: "No todo el verde es igual".
Quizá estamos cambiando la magnificencia del bosque tropical y toda esa diversidad
por, no sé, espuma verde de estanque o césped o algo así.
SB: Según este estudio en particular, todo tipo de planta está aumentando.
Ahora, curiosamente el estudio no incluye qué demonios está pasando en los océanos.
La producción primaria en los océanos,
la biota de los océanos, microbiana en su mayoría, ¿en qué se halla?
Quizá eso sea lo más importante.
Ellos son los que crean la atmósfera que dichosamente respiramos
y no son parte del estudio.
James Lovelock ha estado insistiendo en esto:
nuestros conocimientos de los océanos, especialmente de la vida marina,
es fundamentalmente vapor.
Así que estamos en el proceso de descubrir,
debido a la inadvertida mala geoingeniería de demasiado CO2 en la atmósfera,
qué es lo que el océano está haciendo con eso.
Bueno, el océano está creciendo con el calor extra.
Por eso es que están subiendo los niveles del mar,
y va a haber más de eso con el calentamiento.
Los arrecifes de coral están sufriendo estragos,
por ejemplo los de Australia.
En La Gran Barrera hay mucho blanqueamiento por el sobrecalentamiento.
Y es por esto
que Danny Hills y yo, en nuestra sesión previa en el escenario principal,
decíamos que vale la pena experimentar con la geoingeniería
para ver qué es lo que funciona.
Para ver si podemos ganar tiempo en cuanto al calentamiento,
ajustar el sistema con pequeños estudios prácticos
y así saber si debemos hacer más que ajustar.
CA: Bien, esto es de lo que hablaremos los últimos minutos
porque es muy importante.
Primero que todo, este libro fue publicado recientemente
por Yuval Harari.
Dice que la siguiente evolución de los humanos es convertirse en dioses.
Creo que él...
SB: Ud. ha hablado con él y, probablemente, ya terminó el libro,
yo todavía no lo termino.
¿En qué parte dice...?
CA: Es un punto de vista muy radical.
Cree que
nos reinventaremos por completo usando información, usando bioingeniería
para convertirnos en creaturas totalmente nuevas con algo así como superpoderes,
y que habrá muchísima desigualdad.
Que estamos por escribir un muy radical y nuevo capítulo de la historia.
Eso es lo que cree.
SB: ¿Está Harari nervioso al respecto?
CA: Está nervioso, pero creo que también
le gusta provocar a la gente.
SB: ¿Está Ud. nervioso al respecto?
CA: Estoy nervioso, pero hay tantas cosas en TED que me emocionan y ponen nervioso.
El optimista en mí trata de inclinarse hacia:
"Esto es fantástico y muy emocionante", mientras mi lado responsable dice:
"Tal vez debiéramos tener cuidado en cuanto a cómo lo enfocamos".
SB: Esa es la receta secreta de TED, ¿no?, mantenerse nerviosos y emocionados.
CA: También es la receta para ser un poco esquizofrénico.
(Risas)
Pero Harari no lo citó a Ud.
La que me pareció una declaración sorprendente
fue la que Ud. hizo en el 'Whole Earth Catalog' original,
cuando lo concluyó con esta poderosa frase:
"Somos como dioses, así que mejor que aprendamos a hacerlo bien".
Y recientemente hizo una nueva versión de la declaración.
Quiero hablar de esa filosofía.
SB: Estoy aprendiendo
que la documentación es mejor que la memoria, de largo.
Y hay algo que aprendí de alguien...
Entré a Twitter, cambió mi vida;
Ryan [la esposa] todavía no me perdona.
Me apropié de esa frase cuando alguien la citó, y alguien más dijo:
"Por si acaso, eso no fue lo que escribió en el 'Whole Earth Catalog' de 1968.
Escribió: 'Somos como dioses y más vale que nos acostumbremos'".
Había olvidado eso.
(Risas)
Estas benditas historias que nos contamos a nosotros mismos
se convierten en mentiras con el tiempo.
Así que la documentación ayuda a acabar con eso.
Sí evolucionó a "Somos como dioses, mejor que aprendamos a hacerlo bien",
y ese fue el 'Whole Earth Catalog'.
Cuando estaba haciendo un libro
titulado 'Whole Earth Discipline: An Ecopragmatist Manifesto',
a la luz del cambio climático dije que somos como dioses
y que tenemos que hacerlo bien.
CA: "Somos como dioses y tenemos que hacerlo bien".
Hable de eso porque la reacción psicológica de tanta gente
en cuanto escuchan de geoingeniería
es que lo último que debieran ser los humanos es dioses,
algunos por motivos religiosos, pero la mayoría por humildad
porque los sistemas son demasiado complejos y no debiéramos entrometernos.
SB: Bueno, es la narrativa griega sobre la arrogancia.
El que empieza a sentirse realmente seguro de sí mismo
termina durmiendo con su propia madre.
(Risas)
CA: No esperaba que dijera eso.
SB: Es la historia de Edipo.
La arrogancia es un ejemplo admonitorio muy importante que no debe olvidarse.
Una de las pautas que he seguido en mi vida es:
cada día me pregunto en cuántas cosas estoy totalmente equivocado.
Mi formación es como científico
y trabajo con científicos en estos días, lo que es alegría pura,
y la ciencia es escepticismo organizado.
Así que uno siempre está insistiendo, incluso cuando todo luce maravillosamente
uno mantiene un conjunto de sospechas:
¿es esto tan bueno como parece?, y también se pregunta qué más está pasando.
Creo que este "¿Que más está pasando?",
lo que lo mantiene alejado a uno de las noticias falsas.
No son necesariamente noticias reales,
pero le da la bienvenida
a noticias más complejas que uno está tratando de comprender.
CA: Pero regresando a la aplicación de esto al medio ambiente:
parece que según esta filosofía, nos guste o no,
dominamos muchos aspectos de lo que pasa en los planetas
y lo hacemos involuntariamente,
así que debiéramos empezar a hacerlo deliberadamente.
¿Cómo luciría empezar a dominar el arte de ser dioses?
¿Cómo empezamos a hacer eso?
¿Hay experimentos a pequeña escala o sistemas con los que podamos jugar?
¿Cómo lo concebimos?
SB: El mentor que me liberó de mi adhesión total a Buckminster Fuller
fue Gregory Bateson.
Gregory Bateson era un epistemólogo, antropólogo,
biólogo, psicólogo y muchas otras cosas.
Bateson observaba cómo los sistemas se ven a sí mismos.
Y creo que, en parte, es así cómo debiéramos querer ver las cosas siempre.
Lo que me gusta de la postura de David Keith en cuanto a la geoingeniería
es que no solamente te lanzas y ya.
El método de David Keith,
esto es de lo que Danny Hills estaba hablando hace un momento,
es que lo haces gradualmente,
haces cosas para ajustar el sistema y ves cómo responde,
eso te informa sobre el sistema.
Esa es la respuesta para la gente que dice, con razón:
"¿De qué estamos hablando?
No entendemos cómo funciona el sistema del clima.
No puedes diseñar un sistema que no entiendes".
Y David dice: "Lo mismo aplica al cuerpo humano,
sin embargo, la medicina sigue adelante, y nos alegra que así sea".
La manera de diseñar un sistema
que es tan amplio y complejo que no se puede entender totalmente
es ajustándolo.
Y es un método antiarrogancia: se prueba un poquito aquí,
se retrocede si eso creó un problema,
se lo expande si todo parece ir bien.
Mientras, se mantienen abiertos otros caminos.
Esta es toda la discusión sobre diversidad y diálogo y todas esas otras cosas,
y todo lo que escuchamos antes de Sebastian.
Así que el método antiarrogancia es buscar la licencia social,
que creo que es una terminología acertada que incluye lo suficiente a la sociedad
en estos temas interesantes, problemáticos y profundos
para que tengan una bastante buena idea de ellos,
y debe haber gente en la que confían prestando detenida atención
a los experimentos que se realizan;
y se mantiene el diálogo público,
que es más público que nunca antes, lo cual es fantástico.
E instintivamente,
simplemente sigues tu camino,
que es el camino enmarañado que ha estado funcionando bastante bien hasta ahora.
Sebastian y yo somos así de optimistas
porque leemos a gente como Steven Pinker, 'Los ángeles que llevamos dentro'.
Y hasta ahora todo marcha bien.
Ahora, eso siempre puede cambiar,
pero uno puede enfocarse en que las cosas son capaces de mejorar,
identificar qué herramientas ayudaron a la mejoría y usarlas más.
Así es la cosa.
CA: Stewart, creo que concluiremos con ese comentario optimista.
Me deslumbra
cómo siempre está dispuesto a cuestionarse a sí mismo y a otros.
Creo que esa receta de nunca permitirse estar demasiado seguro
es increíblemente poderosa.
Quiero aprenderla.
Ha sido muy esclarecedor e inspirador escucharlo hoy.
Stewart Brand, muchísimas gracias.
SB: Gracias.
(Aplausos)